[Music]
when people like on the phone they they
they tell me oh hello mr. it always like
gives us like a little spark or
something me I like my identity as as
being trans and I'm just so proud of it
that I wanted like maybe a shout out out
of the rules because I can conquer
everything I guess
and so i'm sanna i'm a identify as a man
a transgender man actually being
transgender means that you're you
identify differently
with the gender they were assigned at
Birth you have two types of transition
you have social transition and medical
transition and for most of trans people
they do like the social transition that
means if you're a trans man and you
start to live as a man and like the
medical transition is like yeah the real
medical steps you need to take like
hormone therapy some operations you can
do but not all trans people do these
medical steps so I started taking
testosterone on the 8th of August 2017
so a year and a half right now and from
that moment yeah it's it helped me to be
the man I needed to be and like all the
people to see me as a man I am so yeah
to me that that date is like very very
important many patients who come for
hormone treatment somehow they're still
kind of worried and together with them
their families and also maybe their GPS
or other doctors that hormone treat
treatment will induce something bad that
they will have more cardiovascular
disease that I will have more hormone
related cancers yeah so I guess I I
don't want to think about it a lot
because if I would it would be a some
kind of a nerve wracking because yeah I
have no idea what this hormone will do
to my body when I finished finish my PhD
what you found the literature was small
k-series a lot of opinions a lot of
expert
opinion papers but very little
well-structured research so what we
study that we are conducting now we set
out to look for the longer term effects
and side effects of hormone treatment
and trans people and what we found is
that people are doing very well do
people have side effects do you see
anything in the blood that goes wrong
and in fact I really have to do an
effort to find anything that goes wrong
and those blood results and we've
documented that on the very large number
of patients now there are still quite a
lot of colleagues who are opposed to
normal treatment and trans people and I
just want to show with my research that
hormonal treatment and trans people is
not very difficult that it helps your
patients a lot that they really need it
so I want to break down their arguments
one by one and hopefully more of my
colleagues will get involved when I was
little like I think three years old or
something I hope I used to dress up as a
girl because it felt really normal to me
till people started telling me that I
had to dress up to my gender I was born
in to a boy and I kept doing it in
secret until it couldn't be a secret
anymore I find it hard to to explain how
it feels to be like this because I was
really born like this I was like really
like really natural to me to become this
and it's hard to explain to someone who
is not that I I don't have a choice that
I just feel female and there is nothing
in me that once thought that I was male
I got really depressed and I I couldn't
like live with the body for yeah you
have to wait for the operation very long
and I insert important in my life that
was the only thing keeping me alive
sometimes because when something bad
used to happen I used to like count down
in my head still so many days on my
oppression and I couldn't start living
around 50% of trans person suffer from
depression around 30% suffer from
anxiety and about 35% have a suicidal
ideation or have attempted suicide at
some point
transgender persons suffer a lot from
everyday harassment and exclusion and so
you might think that very high rates
that are present in trans persons of
anxiety disorders and depression might
be partly due to this omnipresent
ostracism an difficult the most
difficult part of like that reminds me
that I'm not normal
is dating dating is really hard because
at a certain point you have to tell your
partner yeah that you're transgender or
was transgender and some boys in my case
they don't seem to like ya they think
it's bad then they don't want to see me
down anymore I've had that like a couple
of times now so at a certain point I
just stopped dating because there was
like a trigger for me to get depressed
the central hypothesis that we're
testing is that people who are
particularly vulnerable to social
rejection experience will be at
increased risk for continuing to suffer
from mood and anxiety disorders or
suicidal ideation even even after
they've transitioned into their
preferred gender identity so now a new
project we will experimentally induce an
experience of social rejection and
ostracism experience and we will measure
them how the heart rate is responding
how the pupil is for example dilating or
constricting or the sweating response is
in response to this ostracism experience
so the idea is that we want to follow
people up during the transition process
and after transition we then want to ask
the participants how their mental health
is how they are feeling and then we want
to see whether the variables from the
experiment such as their their heart
rate or the pupil dilation can predict
us the mental health state of the trans
person and how well they're doing this
might be very useful for us to know
because it might help us identify which
particular individuals are in need of
further psychological care during and
after the transition
well I think it's very good that there's
being researched on because I think
there's still a lot to be learned on
scientific level and I also think is
very important to ask questions to trans
people themselves what needs to be
studied now I see the man I I I always
was that to me is like priceless so yeah
I wouldn't go back for like a million
dollars
[Music]
ah duck again